[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coming down to this neighborhood is as
iconic a thing in New York as you can do
all right for a number of different
reasons which we're going to talk about
today all right in the shadow of New
York Stock Exchange a walking tour
starts a two-hour stroll of sights and
stores but this isn't about the normal
City stuff
there's no Statue of Liberty or Empire
State Building on this route this is all
about money there's no more iconic
business in New York than the business
of Finance Jim White's a former banker
he now tells tourists about how Wall
Street imploded a decade ago this is the
height of the housing boom shall we call
it a bubble yes we shall all right
the height of the housing bubble and
then all of a sudden what happens it
jacks and how one name became synonymous
with the global financial crisis the
name of the bank the collapse of Lehman
Brothers was like a tremendous shock to
the system
they've been in New York for a long long
time by 2008 Lehman's was America's
fourth biggest investment bank now
resident in this building which was to
become sadly familiar as the backdrop to
images like this
[Music]
after century-and-a-half LeMans
collapsed it was and he still by far the
biggest corporate bankruptcy in history
word spread very quickly and there were
people as as everyone has seen people
coming out of the building that night
the boxes and in the middle of the night
we got an email which said that the firm
had filed for bankruptcy but that you
should continue to come to work unless
your manager told you otherwise so I
didn't sleep very much that night Lynne
gray spent more than a decade at LeMans
when her team lost their jobs they came
to this bar over the road to mark the
moment when a famous respected banker
went bankrupt I never expected to leave
I expected to end my career at Lehman
Brothers we've had reunions every year
here and it's not the worst celebrating
that we put something over on people or
anything like that we just like to be
together
Lehman's was brought down by debt and
cashflow punctured by the toxic effects
of a collapse in the american housing
market and Lehman's wasn't alone America
had fallen for the idea that house
prices would only ever go up and finance
companies rushed to offer mortgages to
just about anyone it was a bubble and it
burst
Lehman's collapsed and the US government
decided not to bail out the company or
its staff
[Music]
well there's no question that the global
financial crisis had its roots in
America's housing market but not just in
the prices that people paid it was about
what banks did with all that mortgage
debt they created a new financial
product called a collateralized debt
obligation a CDO a bundle of good and
bad mortgages that were traded around
here's how the process worked at the top
were the triple A's the mortgages you
could rely on good borrowers and then
you get less and less reliable this is
still pretty ok but then when you get
down here it's a bit more iffy and these
other subprime borrowers the people who
borrowed more money than they could
afford and when the housing market
started to go south
these ones may have been okay but if you
took out this level the whole economy
collapsed amidst the rubble millions of
American homes were repossessed
unemployment doubled and the US
government which had refused to bail out
Lehman's now found vast sums to prop up
the rest of the financial sector there's
a big package because it was a big
problem
and and you know I tell her I will tell
our citizens and continue to remind them
that the risk of doing nothing far out
raised the risk of the package
Lehman's executives became hate figures
of the crisis the bank's chief executive
Dick Fuld has barely appeared in public
since this bruising encounter at a
congressional hearing is that fair for
the CEO of a company that's now bankrupt
to have made that kind of money and I
believe the amount that I took out of
the company over and above that was
I believe a little bit less than 250
million still a large number though his
former colleagues will keep low profiles
but now I'm off to meet one of the
people who led Levin's Tom Russo the
bank's chief legal officer he was also
its managing director unless you get
history straight and honest you're never
gonna learn from it and so from my point
of view I think history on Lehman in
particular is just dead wrong he spoke
exclusively to Sky News I remember that
that weekend I was in the middle of it
and we sent over a document I think was
on that Saturday that went through all
the things that would happen if Lehman
were to go bankrupt detailed list and I
remember being on the phone with many
people at the Fed and then fundamentally
we ran out of time a decade on he's
still angry still convinced that the
government's decision not to bail out
Lehman's was the catalyst for the global
crisis that followed the reason why
Lehman was sacrifice was because it was
a miscalculation on that weekend that if
Lehman were let go we could weather the
storm and I think Lehman was a victim
because they saved everyone else they
could have just easily let Goldman or
Morgan Stanley or Merrill Lynch or they
could let AIG the coletta
number of people fail the political mood
in the economy in the country was no
more bailouts so they really wanted to
make an example and so I think it was a
bad judgment call
very bad judgment call that signal was
the the signal that really put in
jeopardy the financial
world about an hour from Tom Rousseau's
New Jersey home is the state's largest
city new it proud old place with a
vibrant young community still filling
the impact of the global downturn you've
lived through a financial crisis and
nervous are you that another one could
happen because if you don't secure your
financial future for yourself and you're
working with someone a financial crisis
you can always have it it's been an
entrepreneur if you have a dream you
something you want to pursue you don't
let that financial crisis get in your
way and we're still recovering people
lost their homes they're trying to build
back their their treasure full of income
and wealth
do you trust banks and bankers no no I
don't know because they've got in the
past they haven't given us any return on
our on our money that we put into them
and deposits and they don't give us
loans so no we don't trust
during the crisis this state was third
worst in America for home repossessions
known as foreclosures now it's moved up
to first on that
sorry list and the very worst hit area
is here Essex County hi my name is
Loretta Hill Loretta was a nursing
assistant who was miss old a mortgage
that she couldn't possibly afford it was
very hard you know for a lot of times we
didn't have food you know it was very
hard you know not knowing from
day-to-day what's gonna happen they
gonna foreclose I'm getting these
notices we're foreclosing I'm panicking
it's legal documents I'm not legally I'm
not a lawyer I'm not understanding this
all I know is damn I paid for this house
and and now I'm gonna lose it walk
around this bit of New Jersey and you
see plenty of scars left over from the
last financial crisis whether it's
repossessed homes or cratered property
prices and we know what happened in 2008
it was all a result of reckless lending
to people who couldn't afford a mortgage
and the US government's done a lot to
try to make sure that those
circumstances don't happen again
but while regulators have concentrated
on avoiding a repeat of the subprime
crisis is it possible that another storm
has been brewing this time based on the
growing mountains of debt held by
American companies and by the government
and there are people here convinced that
that will be the catalyst for the
world's next financial crisis in fact
they fear it may already have begun
the crisis led to low interest rates and
much more borrowing US companies and now
more than six trillion dollars in debt
so should we worry that some companies
won't cope without debt burden I'm
heading back to Manhattan to talk to one
of America's most respected banking
analysts these companies now have
borrowed pretty significantly and so if
they don't really have a viable business
or their businesses impacted by
something in the economy or rates go up
their coverage that which is now quite
good of the interest rate expense could
take a different turn and that's the
concern as as rates move up can these
companies that have borrowed so much
really have the wherewithal to pay back
the debt that they that they took on
debt is everywhere in the States
the US government owes 21 trillion
dollars more than the GDP of this the
richest and perhaps boldest country in
the world we get things done creating
millions of new jobs so this man is
crucial no not President Trump but the
man with him Jerome Powell chairman of
the Federal Reserve the man who wants to
push up America's interest rates
economists and Pettifer predicted the
financial crisis two years before the
collapse of LeMans she now worries that
rising rates in America will spark the
next global crisis so timing is
difficult but I can say with some
confidence that the rise in interest
rates is going to be the trigger of the
next crisis in mr. mr. power has
promised us that he was going to raise
interest rates every month of this year
into next year so you know he's laying
in my view he's laying the ground of the
next crisis well I think it'll be worse
than the last crisis because we won't
have the tools we had during the last
crisis it'll be really difficult to
start pumping out quantitative easing to
start buying back all those assets
already the new crisis has begun to roll
we should
those warnings the financial crisis in
2008 shaped the modern world it led to
austerity political division perhaps to
brexit and the election of Donald Trump
who knows what change the next one could
bring I think the seeds of the next
financial crisis are properly being
ordered right now
that is what got everybody into trouble
in 2008 and it could get everybody into
trouble so so you're gonna have booms
and busts and something like what
happened in 2008 is gonna happen again
so keep your hat on and your seatbelt
fastened
[Music]